What do you think that maybe they hired
Donald Trump because they knew there was
so many Republicans that are shitheads.
They could just get him to the podium and
then he would crumble under the weight
of Hillary Clinton. It's the greatest
professional wrestling act ever, ever.
Really is
gone to build
it's crazy hair.
Could you imagine given that due to pot
cookie and a mirror and go, hey bro,
what's going on up here? What is this?
What's going on? What are you doing?
This is, this is madness.
If you have, you know,
you just go like short trimmed
hair with some bald spots.
That's way more gangster than what
you're doing. Like what you're doing.
It's kind of crazy.
Hair does not look like that.
It just doesn't look like
that ever in the wild.
It just like what you've done is you've
used some sort of chemicals to concoct
something and his face.
Is it really that?
Is that the lading or is it
really that red and orange?
They do him up in the kind of people that
do him up or probably like the kind of
people that really like him and
they kind of like some orange skin.
They want to fight both of them.
It's warping that they want to fight.
It's white people warpaint
but why doesn't he do the under eyes?
Like if you're going to do your whole,
your face like that.
Do you think he wears like giant goggles
when he gets in the tanning booth?
Is that what's going on?
Like why is this a
eyes just white? Surely he knows
what he looks like. Right? But then,
but then you look at his hair and you
go, well why is he doing that? Then.